depuis ses débuts il ya plus de 25 ans
le web est une affaire de pays riches
mais plus pour très longtemps si on se
fie à la provenance des internautes car
selon les prévisions les plus récentes
les citoyens des pays émergents
s'apprêtent à arriver massivement en
ligne mathieu bonsoir céline alors c'est
un marché énorme qui intéresse déjà les
géants du web c'est une révolution c'est
d'imaginer on est actuellement environ 3
milliards d'internautes d'ici deux ans
c'est un milliard de plus ces 30% c'est
l'équivalent des populations combiné des
états unis de l'indonésie du brésil du
nigeria et du pakistan c'est énorme ces
internautes là vont partager une
caractéristique plusieurs en fait
caractéristique ils sont branchés
massivement avec des applications
mobiles ils vont avoir accès à internet
par le biais d' immense réseau sans fil
mais le sans fil est ce que c'est parce
qu'on utilise les gens mais en fait non
le sans fil c'est au bout de la chaîne
par exemple votre téléphone se connecte
en bande sans fil ici mais l'heure reste
des connexions ça fonctionne par câble
faut pas oublier leur qu'actuellement en
fait en 2014 internet c'est 263 câbles
sous-marins ont partout dans le monde 22
ans projet ça c'est des chiffres de l'an
dernier et qui sont reliés à des centres
de données c'est sans internet est très
physique des centres de données relié
par câble et donc c'est cette manière de
faire transiter le signal qui va être
remis en confiance un grand changement
de paradigme parce que là le filaire ça
coûte très cher on s'en rend compte sur
nos factures et dans les pays émergents
bayane le pote de réseaux filaires on va
pas aller collecter et à rajouter des
ddd câble qu'au milieu du sahara on va
sauter une étape à l'avant que des
grands conglomérats qui sont sur les
blocs de départ actuellement pour amener
le signal par les airs alors ça c'est
vraiment très nouveau par exemple on
retrouve facebook facebook dans ses
cartons un projet hallucinant ce sont
des drones donc des centaines de drones
qui seront à 20 kilomètres d'altitude et
qu'ils vont communiquer entre eux par
des lasers des drones alimentées à
l'énergie solaire qui pourront rester en
l'air pendant des mois et avec lesquels
on va communiquer directement n'en
oubliez le fil donc ça va être
directement avec le drone en au yoyo
google également le google leur pari ce
sont des ballons c'est le projet lounes
alors imaginez vous une armée de ballons
les milliers de ballons en haute
altitude communique encore entre eux et
qu'ils peuvent changer de direction ils
sont au courant des vents dominants et
quand on a le ballon sort d'une zone
mais les repères un vin et l'oeil va
monter il va les chercher un autre
courant pour revenir dans la zone ça
c'est le projet de google google fait
aussi partie d'un conglomérat qui veut
mettre des satellites par dizaines en
orbite y en a déjà douces et le
conglomérat haute hui be il y en a un
autre c'est one way a dû coûter y en a
énormément le wan web c650 petits
satellites pochette 350 mille dollars
pièce qu'on veut mettre en orbite ayant
finalement space x avec le fameux il une
mosquée dernière les mobilités cela qui
est un projet de 10 milliards de dollars
pour mettre une armée de scat de 4000
satellites en orbite langues vraiment si
c'est énorme il donc ces projets là ils
devraient ils devraient commencer quand
ils sont déjà en train d'être mises en
service son horizon de cinq ans et tout
ce b pour aller chercher cette fabuleuse
manne imaginer des domaines dans la
haute technologie où on a des taux de
croissance de 30 % sur deux ans il y en
a pas alors c'est pour ça que ces gens
là sont lost un formidable marché sont
pas des philanthropes h ça va changer la
vie de bien des gens est la nôtre aussi
on sera en minorité très bientôt
l'occident en ligne si vous matière
plaisir céline